[Music]
welcome to the table everyone wherever
you are we are so glad that you are here
as well and just to get us all in the
same place at the same time we wanted to
open with a little meditation to steal
your heart and quiet your mind and bring
us all truly together be still and know
that I am God be still and to know that
I am be still and know still
[Music]
[Applause]
God goes longing to every broken thing
he's made see his being simply by being
the thing that is stone and tree and sky
man who sees and sings and wonders why
God goes belonging to every broken thing
he's made means a storm of peace think
of the atoms inside the stone think of
the man who sits alone trying to will
himself into a stillness where God knows
belong to every broken thing he's made
there is given one shade shaped exactly
to the thing itself under a tree a
darker tree under the man only the man
to see God goes belonging to every
broken thing he's made the things that
bring him near made the mind that makes
him go a part of what man knows apart
from what man knows God goes belonging
to every broken thing he's me
[Music]
thank you so much Ryan and Mindy and
Maggie that was really beautiful and
good evening and welcome to all of you
our listeners are people that we love so
much I wish I could hug all your faces
yet again
but alas here we are you might be
wondering why we aren't at Pleasant
Valley and that is of course all the
social distancing measures we just we
want to do our part to you know to stop
the spread of this virus and many of us
are having to still like go to work or
do various things out and around and so
we just want to make sure that we're you
know protecting families and and taking
care of each other in that way so anyway
that's why we're kind of doing it in
this way but I'm really grateful huge
shout out and thank you too Gary miner
this week for helping us get like just
all this whole setup going and so thank
you so much Gary but yeah so welcome to
the table
it's super good to be with you all and
before I jump in I wanted to mention
just a few I guess they're basically
announcements so there are two ways that
we still have to stay connected the
first is we call them meetups they're
basically our small groups and those are
still basically happening they're just
meeting online so of course one of the
dangers of everything we're going
through right now is that sense of
loneliness of disconnection and
depression and so I just want to
encourage you if you're not connecting
with a meet-up um to do that if you
don't have a place to find some
community a place to share that's really
really important right now so what you
can do is either just comment below in
the live stream feed or just kick myself
or the table a direct message through
Facebook and just say hey I'd love to
connect with a meet-up and we will we'll
get you connected the other way that
we're trying to stay connected is
through I send basically a weekly I'm
not only an email but also a text to
each person who's kind of a part of our
community or loosely connected and so
it's just I send basically a it can be
usually it's a prayer or a quote and
just something encouraging uplifting and
it's a way for me to kind of check in on
people so at any rate if you'd like to
receive that then again just comment
below or kick the table a message and
we'll make sure that you get on that
list all right so we are in part three
of our incredibly timely series
tranquility cultivating calm in a crazy
world and the premise of this whole
series is basically that it's that it's
stress that destroys our tranquility
some of you are experiencing that in
your lives right now maybe the majority
of us are experiencing this and it's
stress it results from really from that
that sense of worry even a sense of
speed and kind of overwork that lies at
the root of so much of our anxiety and
or like depression and just that you
know that general sense of like
unhappiness that pervades so many of our
lives now and so what we need to do even
here and now you might say especially
here and now in this kind of season is
learn healthier ways of living and
relating to ourselves to others to God
and so that leads me to my message
tonight which is titled simply rest and
there's an ancient story in the early
chapters of the book of Genesis if
you're following along your Bible you
can go to Genesis chapter well it's sort
of one and then I'm gonna quote from the
end of chapter two and most people a lot
of people get kind of lost arguing over
this text like over it's kind of
scientific merit and honestly it seems
to me that this text it's pretty clearly
a myth so poetic account of creation
what I mean by that is it's not like
it's point it's not scientific accuracy
but capital T truth in a much bigger and
broader sense it's trying to speak to
like the truth of who God is who we are
in relationship to him now having said
that I must admit that the account here
is eerily similar to what science in the
last you know hundred plus years or so
has taught us about creation in that
basically it names that God created the
world in in ever higher orders of
complexity and beauty first there was
like light in darkness and then there
was a sky and then the sky lit up with
lights like planets and stars and moons
and then of course there were waters and
then the dry land and then the dry land
produced vegetation and then the living
creatures came first in the waters and
then in the air and then animals and
creeping things upon the dry ground and
then finally on the sixth day God
created
humankind in his own image and you might
think that that's the high point of the
story that God then declared you know
the sixth day holy because well you know
we human beings we are part of the sixth
day but no no the story actually
continues that it was the what day the
next day the seventh day that that's the
day that God blessed
it was the seventh day that God declared
holy sacred wonderful the pinnacle now
this begs the question why why the
seventh day why not our day day six
well Genesis chapter two verse three
names it very clearly it says then God
blessed the the seventh the Sabbath day
and made it holy because on it he rested
so every few weeks well at my worst is
every week but at my best it's like
every few months so I'll just average it
out and I'll just say every few weeks I
reach this point of depletion I've
alluded to this in previous messages in
this series I'm sort of like a like a
bucket whose water has all been poured
out I remember a few months ago this
happened I was helping to lead our
previous church community through a time
of discernment regarding the full
inclusion of LGBTQ folks in the life of
the church and you know for all of its
beauty it was also very difficult and
stressful and then at the same time I
had a big fight with a wonderful friend
and isn't interesting how stress in our
lives it isn't just about the hours we
work
but about the relational dynamics in
your life so I had those things going on
and then of course as many of you know I
was coaching soccer on top of all that
and in this particular weekend I just
had multiple soccer games I was just
stressed out to the max and so was like
a Friday and I was kind of nearing the
end of my workweek and yeah I looked at
my to-do list and I had so much yet to
do it was Friday morning but I'm looking
at this list like oh my gosh and so I'm
standing there at my or sitting there at
my laptop and I could not bring myself
to begin has anyone ever been there like
I opened up my laptop is just sitting
there and I'm just there with my hands
on the keyboard not typing just staring
now whether it's because of stress or
sickness or exhaustion I think this is
something many people can relate to
right this sense of I need to get going
but I have nothing left
you're just you're done do in II done
that's where I was and in in these
moments it's the craziest thing
but this irrational fear it just like
creeps into my mind and this is the the
fear that Brett this is now forever this
is your new life you're the guy who can
get nothing done you will be wildly
inefficient for the rest of your days
you must now accept this as your new
normal and in despair I literally I was
there and I just closed my laptop and I
left my office and I went home I mean
what could I do
like literally nothing and so that's
exactly what I did
nothing nothing productive now I wish I
could say I went on a prayer retreat to
renew myself
but actually I went on a Netflix retreat
because sometimes I'll try to read but
in this case I was so depleted I
couldn't even read books like reading
books was too much energy I just had no
energy and so I just lay there and like
eight hours passes then like I don't
know how many twelve fourteen finally
it's like that time I go to sleep I wake
up the next day I just keep resting like
20 hours 24 hours and then suddenly as
if by magic it lifts now why rest I
simply needed to rest now what's the
principle here if you and I are not
intentional about resting if you and I
are not tuned into our bodies and in
learning to yield to the warning signals
of fatigue eventually that they will
force us to a grinding halt maybe not
today maybe not tomorrow but eventually
it will happen it's almost as though
call me crazy
God has created the world you an eye for
healthy rhythms of work and rest now you
say ah yes Brett I know what you're
talking about you're talking about the
Sabbath the whole six days I work the
seventh day I rest ah yes I think that's
a good rhythm Brett I agree and in fact
I even kind of try to follow that you
know take weekends off and such um yes
the whole we work six days and then we
rest type of rhythm I think that's a
great principle and in fact I just want
to kind of name for this message that
that should be a clear takeaway right
from the sermon is every week should
have its day of rest that's true every
week should have its day of rest
but that's not actually the point of my
message tonight you see because what
Americans do with this and I include
myself very much in this critique is we
say oh okay yes yes six days of work and
one of rest so I are now going to run
myself into the ground for six days and
then I'm going to recover for one day in
other words I'm going to abuse my brain
and body and be profoundly unhealthy for
six days and then I'll take a day to
obey God all right so I just want to
name this very clearly that the Sabbath
this all idea of the seventh day of rest
this is not intended to be a trip to the
spiritual I see you after a week of
abusing your body in mind isn't that
such a profoundly American way of
viewing the Sabbath um so let me give
you two quick these are two quick very
Western very American we'll call them
Miskin misconceptions misunderstandings
of the Sabbath of a day of rest all
right so the first misconception is that
I earn my day of rest by overextending
myself throughout the week can you hear
the logic there it's this is the ernie
model this is where in other words the
day of rest in this kind of thinking
comes you know at the end of the week so
i earn it right I work Monday and
Tuesday Wednesday there's a Friday and
then maybe Saturday and then I get into
us okay now it's Sunday or whatever your
day is right and this is the idea of
kind of the the yeah so I overextend in
order to get to the day of rest now the
other kind of alternative or the other
misconception is this sort of idea that
in the inverse so it's that I rest so
that I can then overextend myself
throughout the week I'm so guilty this
so this is more my preference right so
it's kind of like I start with the rest
I've even heard preachers preach like
this is kind of the spiritual way you
know like you know you begin with rest
you know you in it's not like Ernie no
no you begin with rest and but but where
we get this twisted right is okay I'm
gonna begin with rest again so that I
can abuse my body and mind the next
day's it utterly exhausted myself and
then you know rest again now these are
obviously two sides of the same coin
and they're both unhealthy why well lots
of reasons I mean one obvious thing is
that it really and I think this point
really connects with our series is that
when we do this our stress levels rise
right when we abused our body of mine
for six days our stress levels rise
cortisol adrenaline in our bodies go
through the roof and then because of
this are happy tranquil chemicals go
down which leads to chronic anxiety
depression general unhappiness all right
so that's like the science side of it
but but I want to frame it tonight more
in a spiritual relational sense here's
why I think this matters when we go too
hard and too fast
for too long it a lien AIT's us from
ourselves from others and from God and
we go too hard too fast too long it a
lien AIT's it it brings in the sense of
disconnection from myself from the
people around me from God and I mean
I've experienced this all the time right
because for thinking particularly of my
relationships I'm like with with Maggie
with my kids my friends right when I'm
so depleted it's like I reach this point
of I got I'm sorry I got nothing left
right and this is why um you and I can
technically sort of keep the letter of
the law when it comes to the Sabbath and
yet break the spirit of the law so okay
what's the answer like what do we need
to do if you don't hear anything else
tonight I want you to hear this that we
need to bring the spirit of the Sabbath
into the other six days in our lives
what what do I mean by the spirit of
Sabbath I mean um it's like a spirit of
a vibe of rest of calm of tranquility
into every day every hour every moment
see we're even when I'm working I'm not
striving right that's where we want to
be even when I'm working I'm not
striving even when I'm working my soul
is not straining I'm not stressed out
but instead I am
well now you might wonder how on earth
would we do that
and so let me go ahead and give you two
suggestions
tonight two ways of bringing the spirit
of Sabbath the the spirit of rest
into like your everyday life all right
so the first is this
you've got to resist the temptation to
cram more in I'm thinking you know into
your life I love that in the poetic
creation story of Genesis that I read
earlier it doesn't say that on the
seventh day the Sabbath day God realized
that he had oh my gosh a whole extra day
and so we made sure to maximize his
efficiency he made sure to bring every
last drop of production in from every
moment no God did not use the seventh
day to cram more in my mentor Keith
Spurgeon he put it this way he said fill
a calendar drain a life in other words
there comes a point where we have like a
rich life you know a good life it's a
full it's full but what happens which is
so tempted or just to keep adding right
we just keep cramming more in this is
from dr. Archibald Hart in his wonderful
book the anxiety cure
linked to in my my e letter I think was
two weeks ago it's a wonderful wonderful
book but he says this we are so
determined to succeed that most of us
try to pack each moment of the day with
activity some of this activity is
necessary if we're going to eat raise
healthy well-fed kids save for
comfortable retirement but we go beyond
this we are so determined to get to our
destination the success fame recognition
wealth that we never take time to
reflect on the journey of life
to enjoy the scenery or be grateful that
we are on a journey at all isn't this
art great temptation to took it's like
we're constantly living for tomorrow you
know next week like we can be so
goal-oriented and goals aren't bad but
we can be so goal-oriented that it's
like we're forever working towards
getting you know there and yet in the
missing the glory the beauty all around
us we've got to resist the temptation to
cram more and we need the discipline of
saying enough in in fact some of you I
mean probably you're like me right in
this season we're kind of forced not to
cram as much in and although there's
real challenges to this like the some of
the social ice so social isolation and
all that can be really challenging and
yet I my hunch is your your calendar is
less full right now and just ask
yourself has there been an element in
your life where that has actually been
good like a good thing we've got to
resist the temptation to cram more in we
need the discipline of saying enough
it's enough all right so that's first
the second way that we can begin to
bring the spirit of Sabbath into every
day every hour every moment is quite
simple but it's not easy
number two go slower mmm this is hard we
have such a hurry sickness I got that
language from dr. Hart my quota just
second ago his hurry sickness I love
that phrase because that's really what
it is like we have such a hurry sickness
in our culture we're always trying to go
faster drive faster type faster read
faster email faster just faster faster
faster I mean if you want like a
successful product in the world help
people either save time or go faster and
that thing will sell because we are
we're like addicted to kind of speed and
we do we have this kind of hurry
sickness I love this quote this is from
the poet Jack Gilbert and from his book
of poems titled refusing heaven and he
wrote these words he said the Grand
Italian churches are covered with detail
which is visible at the pace people walk
by the great modern buildings are blank
because there is no time to see from the
car a thousand years ago when they built
the gardens of Kyoto the stones were set
in the streams Askew whoever went
quickly would fall in when we slowed the
garden can choose what we notice can
change our heart and when I think of the
Lord Jesus I think of someone who has so
unhurried someone who through the spirit
was so deeply connected to the one that
he called father which is why he could
say I don't do anything but
when I see the father doing I don't say
anything except what I hear the father
say and when we learn to slow down when
we are more present when we through the
spirit are united with God suddenly God
chooses what we notice who we notice
what we say how we say it suddenly God
can change our hearts a church that's
what the world needs right now that's
what our church community needs right
now that's what your family needs right
now a transformed people who don't do
anything except what the father is doing
who don't say anything except what the
father is saying we bow your heads and
close your eyes
let me go ahead and pray Lord God how
did you teach us to slow down in this
season where it's like we are being
forced into a certain kind of slowness
and yet so often it's in the mind God
it's a battlefield but the mind our
minds are early our minds are still full
our minds are still racing and so god I
pray for the game over every person
hearing my voice right now God peace
mine they well in their body well in
their money
help us to slow down
so that you can choose what we noticed
and through that God transform us it
gives us begins God restored to us the
gift of tranquilly change our hearts
good the life-changing name of Jesus I
pray well thank you so so much for
joining us tonight and don't forget if
you're meeting some connection and
honestly I know you are needing some
connection you may not feel it right now
and then you will I encourage you go
ahead get connected to a meet-up get
connection with my prayer text like just
find ways to connect now before you hit
the phone in those places
oh I'm just I don't say that to scare
you
but just as a sober reminder connection
before we need it you can just reach out
kick me a direct message or the table
bag message will get you up let me send
you out with this benediction you are
God's servants if did with trees you're
gifted with visions and upon who rest
the grace of God like flame of fire
go love third the Lord in the strength
please God be with you all
wonderful wonderful Mindy Ryan
[Music]
thanks everybody thank you